I’ve had a long interest in physics and
math ever since middle school.
But, I was discouraged to choose these two
as my major when I went to college.
And that’s because my family thought that
I would have a hard time to find a job
with this major as a female, based on what
we saw at that time in China.
So instead I chose Biology as my major and
it opened a new door for me.
It actually provided the foundation for my
current research and it also lead me to a
beautiful world of evolution and life science.
For my Ph.D., I chose computational biology
because
it is a major that combines my passion in
computation and my interest in biology.
For a long time I observed that for computer
scientists, if they wanted to
understand biomedical data they needed to
have a good understanding of biology.
For biologists, if they wanted to speed the
discovery they required the help of computer scientists.
And my background sort of bridged this gap.
I think we’re at a great stage where we
can actually have the ability to turn data
into actionable items that can be directly
applied to medical decision making.
Data science and the microbiome combined to
improve our health
NLM is one of the few places where I can start
my research program in data science.
There is a critical mass of truly exceptional
and top-notch scientists here.
And I also found people in NLM are approachable.
From the director to the top scientist,
you can just knock on their door and talk
with them and they are always willing to help.
NLM is the place where I can do the research
that I love and enjoy
and also make a difference at the same time.